this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so much for inviting me and to
everyone for
you know coming out on what's been
obviously a very crazy and stressful
semester for everyone so i really
appreciate when anyone does anything
extra right now
and i'm definitely impressed by the
scope of the audience so i really
appreciate you coming
i'm going to go ahead and share my
slides
so thank you so much for that
introduction i am laura ann minkoff cern
i teach at syracuse university in our
food studies program
i'm also the graduate director there so
i'll just do a little
um plug on our program because it's
still relatively new
but we teach about food studies and food
systems we have an undergraduate program
as well as a master's degree program
and it's a mix of the critical social
sciences and then students also get to
take advantage of the maxwell policy
school as well as some students doing
some course work at esf
that want a bit more of the applied
agriculture side of things but we think
it's a pretty
unique program i feel very lucky to have
landed here in syracuse and
and i get to teach about food and food
systems and sustainability
all the time which is um really
wonderful for me
um but i'm gonna talk a bit about the
research that i've been doing
for the past i guess the book now by the
time the book actually gets published
and then all the writing period um so i
really finished the research
about three years ago um the book came
out last
at the end of last year called the new
american farmer
immigration race and the struggle for
sustainability
and this is just a photo of the book
it's with mit press and i always like to
tell people that you can get it
open access you can download it for free
it's one of the books that mit
made open source last year so especially
for grad students that you know
can't just buy every book they want to
read i'm really proud to have it
available
to anyone that wants to read it if you
want to download it from the press site
that is of course if you find this talk
interesting enough that you want to hear
more
um so this book and the talk today
um is the study they did over the course
of about eight years
um looking at latino and latina
immigrant farmers in the united states
and i've i've chosen to
at least for this publication use the
term latino and latina rather than
latinx simply because that's how people
identified themselves to me in
interviews and i wanted to
to honor how people were identifying
themselves um
so my study is qualitative
i'll go a little bit into my methods and
how i did my research in a minute
um but i do always like to point that
while my study is qualitative
it's interview based and i can't make a
lot of quantitative
claims based on my own research it
is backed up by quantitative research
done by the usda census
so my study looked at latino and latina
immigrant farmers united states and i
specifically was doing research with
farm workers that identified as
as immigrants as latino
primarily from mexico
and the census actually looks
at a broader scale of
of self-identified latino or hispanic
farmers
um but what i found in my study and what
is identified in the agricultural census
or this
is the same which is that they are a
growing group of farmers in the united
states
um and while the census is broader in
terms of not
everyone that's interviewed is first
generation so in my study i looked
specifically at first generation
people that came and worked in farm work
and then started their own farms
um what we also see from the broader
numbers
is that um latino and hispanic farmers
are increasing and they are the largest
most quickly growing
self-identified ethnic group in
agriculture today so i think that's
really significant and it backs up
everything that i'm going to talk about
today
in terms of why we should care about
this group of farmers what they bring to
agriculture
and the types of shifts that we're
seeing as well as the ways that
they are disadvantaged the challenges
that they face and what we can possibly
do to better incorporate them into
agrarian systems in the u.s
so why this is really important if we're
looking
at broader shifts in u.s agriculture we
know that half of all farm operators
are reaching retirement
and so we really do have a gap in terms
of who wants to farm and who's willing
to farm in the united states if we are
interested in maintaining
local agriculture and regional
agriculture systems
we've seen that most people born into
farming families in the us are not
interested in taking on the farm
obviously we probably everyone here
already knows why
it's really economically difficult to
survive in farming in the u.s
in the global labor market or the global
market as well as the amount of labor
input and how physically challenging and
difficult
it is as a business um
at the same time we see a higher demand
um for
organic food than we can even grow in
the u.s and i'll you'll see why that's
significant
um as well as a higher demand for
regional and local food which
arguably is growing during the pandemic
as we saw kind of
people being there the fear of supply
chain shutting down
and while that didn't happen um the
demand for things like csas and local
food
um seems to be going up um
and yet right we don't have the farmers
coming in
um with the experience and interest in
continuing
these the types of medium and
small-scale farms that i'll talk about
right so arguably what we have is
a population of farm workers that have
the experience and skill in farming
many of whom actually want to own farms
in the u.s
but don't have the capital and other
types of advantages to start those farms
and so that's kind of the gap that we're
seeing and some of the ways that
immigrants
could be filling the gap and in some
ways are
so i like to start with one of the
quotes this is one of the quotes in the
beginning in the book
by one of the farmers that i met in
washington state
and i always ask the farmers you know
why are they doing this a bit of their
story
um and i'll talk much more about you
know that they do this against so many
odds
um but to describe what their motivation
was and
um this one farmer said to me and her
farm is
mariposa farm of course which means uh
butterfly in spanish
she said we wanted to name it mariposa
because you know the story of the
monarchs the monarch butterflies
they need to fly from mexico to canada
some of them die crossing the border to
reach canada
some of the parents die during the trip
but children know how to come back
i think we as latinos have a lot in
common with butterflies because in order
to be here we have to cross the borders
and sadly a lot of times families lose
their loved ones but their children here
the children who are born here always
have the need of knowing their parents
roots
and always go looking for it and that
represented
a lot of the narratives that i heard
from different farmers
is the ways that starting a farm in the
u.s was not just a business but a way to
establish roots
to revisit the traditions and culture
that they had been raised in
in mexico and also to teach their
children about who they were
and where they were from and so i met
with um the
small farm program at cornell this
morning and
um someone in the meeting said you know
is there motivation for them outside of
um economic motivation and yes that was
largely what i found is there was
something more meaningful to them
as to why they were continuing to farm
you know against
so many odds
um so to scale out a bit um the larger
book project
i'm not going to answer all of these
questions today because that's too many
questions to answer
but what i write about in the book is i
look at
right why are they starting their farms
despite challenges i look a lot of the
historic context
that's determined their position in the
current agri-food system what's the
relationship between slavery
african-american farmers and immigrant
farmers today
i look specifically at how race
ethnicity and their citizenship
affect agricultural practices and their
identity
and what this transition from workers to
owners as they say my work really
focuses specifically on farm workers
starting their own farms
um what does it mean for potentially
labor justice
so i started out my research
specifically working with farm workers
and my dissertation
and i was really interested i still am
very interested in farm
worker and farm labor issues um
and that was the the lead into this
project
um and then of course what do
does this group of farmers mean for
alternative agri-food movements
what might it mean to the types of
more sustainable and socially just
changes that we'd like to see in
agriculture today
so i'm going to narrow it down today to
just three of those questions
um so why are they starting their own
farms how does their race ethnicity and
citizenship
affect their practices and identity and
then what's their role
in these growing food movements
of course there's a lot of um literature
that
influences me um and the work that i do
um in a way i bring together a lot of
work in agrarian political economy
with uh oncology with work on agrarian
cultural
um and racial identity and so the
importance
not only of kind of structures in
agriculture in terms of class structure
um and class transition but also the
importance of
um identity and culture to agrarian
transition
as well as the ways that food and
agriculture and food waste are a form of
resistance
to the industrial food system to
the ways that people are exploited and
oppressed in the food system as well as
the ways that people have historically
lost their own food traditions
and so i draw on a lot of different
scholars that look at
food as a form of cultural resistance
um so this is a bit about where i did my
research
so it was across the united states
and in a lot of ways this research
really followed me and my own
path in life in a very practical way i
started my research in the central coast
the northern central coast of california
when i was doing dissertation work
in uh largely monterey salinas
santa cruz counties in california when i
came
to the east coast um to do my
postdoc work in baltimore i started
doing some work in the northern neck of
virginia about three hours south of
washington dc
um and then once i had established
really two
field sites and started doing some
presentations what i found is
different people in conferences and
different places would reach out to me
and say you need to come here you need
to look at this community
i'll host you i'll introduce you to
people but there are latino farmers
where i'm working too
and that's how i really ended up in
washington um
and minnesota um and the hudson valley
um and of course this is by no means
comprehensive of all the places across
the united states
that i think immigrant farmers and
latino farmers specifically are
succeeding and have pockets um there are
so many more places they could have done
the work
but at a certain point i wanted to write
the book
so um they what i found is really
i think in most areas that have large
farm worker immigrant farm worker
populations
where they have proximity to an urban
area for direct sales
you will find immigrant farming
communities
um so as i said the this work really
looks at this
agriculture agricultural transition or
agrarian transitions so
everyone that i interviewed that was
farming here in the us
um started out in some way farming in
mex
the the vast majority were from mexico
all different parts of mexico
so a few i interviewed were from central
america as well
um but most of them started off farming
um in their life in their home country
they came here to work in the fields
mostly in industrial monocrop
agriculture depending on whatever region
they were in
some of them were migrant workers in the
u.s some of them had worked in northern
mexico before they came here
but largely we're going from
very diversified small scale
agriculture to monocrop
industrial scale agriculture in the
united states
and then they were returning to some
form of
small to medium scale farming and
diversified farming again in the u.s so
they went from farmer to farm worker to
farmer
again and all of them really identified
as a farmer throughout that entire
path and so i think a lot of farm
workers in the u.s identify as farmers
even when they don't
have their own land right even when they
don't have access to make those types of
decisions
and a lot of people would ask me when i
started this work is how can someone
do farm work on someone's farm all day
and then have their own farm in the
evening because many of them had not
made enough money to quit their day jobs
and so they'd do their own farming in
the evening and the weekends
um but what i saw was that what they did
in their day job was
very very different than what they were
doing after work
so in the salinas valley they might be
picking strawberries
all day long with a crew or planting
garlic something
a very very repetitive task where they
didn't get to make any decisions
about how the crop was planted what they
were planning when it was picked
right nothing they were workers they
were told what to do and after work they
would go to their own cloud of land
which they would rent
or own mostly renting um
and they'd be with their extended family
um
they would be in charge of what was
planted they got to make decisions they
were paying attention to the weather
they were they were the farmer right
they were the decision maker
they were doing tons of different jobs
every single day as you do on a small
farm
and it was just an incredibly different
experience to them than working on
someone else's
farm and it was worth it right which
i'll talk about kind of why
why would they do this um
so first the story of as i've been
saying it's kind of this balance between
challenges and opportunities
that the farmers are experiencing so of
course the biggest
as first generation immigrants the us
are race and sedition
citizenship based um
so things such as language the vast
majority
spanish was their first language many of
them had
no to very little english skills in
california in particular and
some in washington state i interviewed a
lot of
self-identified mexican indigenous
farmers
so trichy and meek stucco were their
first languages and then they learned
spanish and mexico and then they were
trying to learn english here
and most had not been you know
beyond middle school some had not been
beyond elementary school so not only
were they not
reading and writing in english many of
them could barely read and write in
spanish
and so a real lack of formal education
which
in the united states farming is actually
quite bureaucratic
if you want to be part of a farmer's
market you have to fill out forms if you
want to own land you have to fill out
forms if you want a business license if
you want to be certified organic
right it's there's tons of paperwork
and while you know a lot of people have
said to me if you want to apply to loans
or
to work with any type of extension um a
lot of people
have said to me well no farmers like
paperwork right no one goes into farming
to do paperwork which of course is true
to have to do that level of paperwork
when you can't read and write in english
is a whole other barrier that keeps
farmers
out of accessing particular resources
and networks
as well as learning how to market in the
context of the united states which is
very different from their home
communities um
you know just the whole concept of
marketing and i and creating a brand and
these types of things
and then of course some of them were
explicitly limited
by citizenship status so i never asked
about citizenship status but i could
usually
kind of you know figure it out along the
lines of their immigration story
um you know and some people if they were
undocumented of course had to
similar to japanese farmers during the
internment period would you know turn
over their licenses
to u.s born children or neighbors or
have someone help them that had
um certification um
and you know many of them also would
experience overt discrimination which i
really
did not hear much discrimination stories
of discrimination by customers it was
largely by other farmers
and market managers and so farmers
market managers
um as well as historical discrimination
by the usda and i'll go a little bit
into that in a minute
um what i realized i actually didn't say
in the methods slide
um maybe i'll go back just one second
um is so my methods for this this was
all
um long-form interview based i
interviewed about 70 farmers or
70 farmers and
30 people in either extension
usda regional usda federal usda
um market managers non-profits and
farm incubators basically anyone i could
find that worked with immigrant farmers
and could tell me about their work with
them i
met a lot of farmers through people in
inc that were working in incubators
farm incubators or um
market managers um and then things would
kind of
um you know extend from there where i
would get to know these extended
networks family networks community
networks of farmers
um but all in all is about 100
interviews
over the course of um of eight years
and different kind of trips um to each
site
multiple trips
so back to kind of the obstacles or
limitations
um i always ask people if they had ever
reach out to extension if they'd ever
reach out to usda
and this is one farmer in california who
is actually a relatively successful
farmer she had gone through
the alba training program one of the
larger farm incubator training programs
in california
she had started her own certified
organic farm
she actually had a spot at many of the
farmers markets in the bay area which is
very competitive
but when i asked you know do you look
for
for grants or loans or any kind of help
and there are
you know there is help out there for
small-scale farmers things like hoop
houses
um you know grants to help them with
value-added products that type of thing
that a lot of small farmers in the us
do access and she said to me well
if you go to an agency and you're a
latino person and you're a woman
and you don't speak the language and you
don't have money and you go to an agency
the federal government
and you want to find someone to speak
your language how do you say this
they don't want to have a person to help
you they don't want to have a person
that speaks your language
um and as we spoke she clearly meant
this not um
you know she meant this metaphorically
as well right first of all there was no
one in the office that spoke spanish
even though
the majority of people in this these
rural areas in california where
farmworkers live
are spanish-speaking um but no one in
her local usda office spoke spanish
um but when she walked in nobody really
wanted to communicate with her because
they assume she's a worker
and i had that really affirmed when i
was doing my research
every area that i was going to interview
farmers i would call
local offices of the usda and any
extension if it existed
and i'd say can i speak with anyone who
works with immigrant farmers in your
region
and i heard multiple times well we don't
work with farm workers
um that would be the labor department
and i'd say no it farmers that they're
i've been talking to farmers and they'd
say well we don't know what you're
talking about
um so many times they're just completely
unaware that the immigrant farmers exist
and they don't identify
immigrants as farmers right it's not who
they see as a farmer
of course this is not always true i
found in washington state
there were a few staff at the usda
that grew up in farm worker families
themselves
that specifically did all the
translation and outreach that made it
their personal
mission to network to all the immigrant
farmers in the area
but it's only because of their own
personal background it's not something
they were being paid to do
or had been hired to do so if there
wasn't an explicit effort
it was not happening
and so of course this has also been um
you know seen historically structurally
so people are usually more familiar with
the pickford case the discrimination
case
of african-american farmers in the usda
but there's also a hispanic and women
farmers women and hispanic farmers were
bunched together in this claims process
there's also a native american farmer's
claims case and this one was
specifically um in 2000 but when i was
doing the early part of my research is
actually when the claims process was
being
processed so 15 years later
people had to hear about this
you could complain if you had been
discriminated against while applying for
a loan from 81 to 2000
which means that you would have had to
be walking into a usda
office um to see the um
the paperwork saying you know if you
were discriminated fill out the
paperwork
of course it's already if you've been
discriminated against you didn't get the
loans
you didn't succeed in farming it's
really hard to ever hear that this is
going on
but still there were many people that
filled out the forms
um successful or successfully um i
should say applied but not successfully
because
in the end um something like 90 of the
cases were thrown out
because they said people didn't fill out
the paperwork properly
which of course to me is really ironic
seeing that what one of the main
practical
barriers that people talked about was
the ability to fill out paperwork um
but in the end right there was
acknowledgement from the usda that this
discrimination had happened and that's
why they had the claims process
um so on the other side of this right
i've talked about the barriers i've
talked about
the um i'm just gonna check on time
um i've talked about the
obstacles um so then it always came to
me that one of the first questions i
would ask great is well why are you
doing this this is so difficult right
anyone familiar with farming knows
that farming is you know economically
difficult it's hard labor
um right it's it's every odd is against
you even if you're us born even if
you're born into a farming family even
if you have capital and resources it's
just very difficult
and you look at people that are coming
here with very little money to invest
very little social networks very little
education and marketing or business
skills
and they're still doing it um and what i
really found this had
this had a lot to do with this sense of
reclaiming
their identity and as i was saying also
reclaiming their
their labor and that that having their
own farm
was very different than working on
someone else's farm
and so they talked to me a lot about
this sense of recreating
you know home recreating the sense of
life in mexico or life back home that
once they had
acknowledged that they were going to
stay here that they wanted to make their
life
you know what they were familiar with
and they wanted to teach it to their
children
and this was reflected as if i was
saying in the scale
so most farms were anywhere from four
acres to the biggest farm i think i saw
was about 60 acres
um and while they were not all certified
organic um
they used kind of low input low spray a
lot of them weren't certified simply
because of the paperwork and cost of
being certified
um and since the book came out i've
actually been working a little bit
with uh nofa the northeast farming is a
northeast organic farming association on
how to make all of their paperwork and
their application process more
accessible
to spanish-speaking immigrants um
because sometimes it's just that it's
not
it has not been apparent right that they
needed to have things in spanish if they
wanted to reach this audience
um and that it can't be like five clicks
to get to the spanish-speaking form
right it needs to be accessible from the
get-go
um so many of them like i said while
they were not
certified um they would fall under the
broad category of alternative
agriculture right
very diversified um you know
low inputs in terms of the scale of
agriculture in the us today
and small scale as well as direct
marketing
um and so while there were some
farmers in california that just
basically could not get into the markets
because they were so saturated
all of them preferred direct markets it
was more familiar to them it's how they
had grown up farming
so that everything from farmers markets
to sometimes selling directly to
mexican grocery stores to directly to
neighbors and people in their own
community
and for them again it was this sense of
controlling their day-to-day
their own labor um as well as preserving
their own
traditional food waste um and so even in
a place where say
they might have had to narrow it down to
three crops because that's what would
sell at market
um on the side they would have their own
you know
milpa or garden so corn beans and squash
or
more of a traditional diet that would
feed their family so no matter what
part of their field would be for their
family
um so it was about much more than a
business right it was about recreating
this sense of home
and familiarity with agriculture for
their family
so this is actually the one farmer that
i interviewed
in the ithaca area um who i've been able
to keep up with
and he said um you know it's part of our
heritage that we want to be able to
knock it up at a certain time but just
jump in a car and
not just jump in a car and leave your
house it's more a way of life being able
to raise your kids at home
because everywhere we're from has their
own farm every single person in town had
their own farm
um and you know for him and his wife it
was
very much about that family about
teaching their kids
how to farm and being part of a local
food system for
their family another farmer in virginia
who had a really beautiful
flower farm where she also had herbs and
vegetables for the market um
she said life in the united states is
very ugly people everyone stays in their
own house there's no time
people live by their watch and there's a
lot of stress and then
you know we were sitting in her living
room having coffee and we were looking
on her farm she's one of the farmers
that actually did own her land
um the land values in virginia
are very low when the farming community
that i was interviewing
started to settle there in the 80s and
she said
on her farm it's a little bit like
mexico it makes me feel the same
it's not the same exactly but more free
in the city there's more pressure
so for her it's not just about the the
practice of being a farmer it's about
the livelihood that she could create
there
um so this is another farmer in
california
and he was one of the farmers that was
really in the salinas valley
like strawberry growing region just
everywhere in strawberries
um and you know his farm really you
could see this very visual contrast
between this very diversified vegetable
farm and
the monocrop strawberries everywhere he
said i like the life of a farmer
i don't necessarily recommend it you
have to love agriculture you need to
love farming more than you love money
one of the first things is you have to
love this you can't do it for the money
that is part of farming right so why
does he continue
um to farm against these barriers
and there's another california farmer um
this was also in reference to kind of
the question of why don't you farm like
everyone around you and he said
they do it for the money and i do it for
the freedom which i think is a really
powerful statement in the context of
people that have immigrated to the us
that have been working on other people's
farms and then choose farming as their
way
um to find freedom on this side of the
border
so as i was speaking to um you know i
don't like to
um it was hard in writing the book to
figure out how to identify
the farmers right is it sustainable is
it small scale is it local right and i
really landed on
alternative as a broad way to describe
the farming i was seeing right which is
that it's relatively small scale
low input in terms of chemical
additives right but not strictly
very diverse and i think that was one of
the most defining features of every farm
that i went to
um direct marketing as well as
prioritizing family labor and of course
that doesn't
you know back to the question that i
brought up of um
labor justice right just because you
have your family working on the farm
doesn't mean that everything's equal and
great um and i did not go very much into
gender dynamics
given kind of the nature of my methods i
most farms
i visited one time i maybe got to know
them in a market and then i was invited
to their home
most of the time it was the male farmer
it was usually a male and female couple
with children
um and it was usually the male farmer
was the farmer even though i could
always
the the female part of the couple would
usually kind of be like adding in all
this information
um so clearly there were some gender um
dynamics going on there always are um
and i didn't really get to ask about
that just given that i was
meeting with most farming families just
one time so all that is to say just
because it's family labor doesn't mean
it's equal
or perfect but in this case i think it's
significant
in terms of agrarian transition because
the family labor was very intentional
and they did not want to scale up for
the most part i'd say would you want to
get bigger do you want to you know have
more property do you want to have more
employees do you want to grow more and
they mostly would say no i really don't
um you know i'm happy at this scale i
want to make this work
i don't want to be in a position of
hiring people like i was being hired
um because you know at the end of the
day they can't afford to pay workers any
more than they were paid
right they're still in the same place of
being stuck in terms of their income
and their ability to do more for their
workers
um and so while they would say to me oh
you know i was a worker so i understand
and this is
some of them did have some workers some
of them that have been around longer
um you know i always give them breaks i
give them gatorade um you know they
weren't essentially
very different employers than people
they had worked for except that they
could speak spanish and they might be
friends
um you know and i think that that just
goes to the structural constraints
of agriculture in the united states
today where farmers are not making
enough money
and not for the most part able to pay a
lot of money and these farmers were no
different
even though they might have wanted to
more than other farmers
so really this leads us to a lot of
questions of course says research always
does
um so immigrant farmers i think are
really important to pay attention to
because it's um an opportunity for us to
better understand the role of low
resource
farmers of farmers of color broadly and
how to make them part
not just of the food system but part of
the alternative food system which we
know
is a growing part of the food system and
there's a desire
for um you know more regional
um more organic foods more local foods
right i don't have to explain what that
means
um but while there's a real plate a role
for them to fill
um because they have all of this
knowledge and skills
they're under the same pressures that
other farmers are right so what i did
see was places where
they'd say well the past i started out
you know with 40 50 varieties but i had
to really narrow it down because the
market i'm selling in i can't sell at
all so then i had to start just selling
tomatoes to this one
you know middle person cooler so the
pressure to
be less diverse in terms of what they
grow was very much there especially in
more competitive markets like the west
coast
um and of course if they're gonna make
it oftentimes they felt they did have to
scale up even when that's not what they
wanted and to hire more non-family labor
meaning hire people at very low cost
um which of course then to this last
point reproduces some of the class
inequalities and the labor issues that
all of agriculture struggles with
and that i started in on this project
wanting to find an answer or find some
kind of solution and i think ultimately
you know the issues are structural
um so i do think that immigrant farmers
play a very important role in our food
system today
a very underappreciated role um there
are a lot of ways we could be reaching
out
much more so um and and
making um especially regional food
systems
places where they are more easily able
to be a part of growing and marketing
and selling their crops
and i think we have a lot to gain from
that in terms of if we're interested in
more ecological
sustainability because i always like to
point out that they're the farmers
they know how to do this right they they
don't know how to market themselves they
don't know how to fill out the paperwork
but they do know how to farm right this
isn't something they need to learn and i
think that's
one of the things that new and beginning
farmers are struggling with in the us
today
if you don't come from an agriculture
background and what we
what i see is that we have farms all
over the us with
sustainable farmers that don't have land
so how do we make that transition i
think is the question
um so this is a quote from a farmer in
washington state that i interviewed he
was renting from a farm incubator called
viva um and he
was um so he was an indigenous immigrant
very young still working his day job um
in the berry fields
in washington um and and really still
just very passionate motivated to go out
at the end of the day and do it again
of course when i asked him why are you
doing this he said if the sun comes out
for everybody
why have envy if it comes out for
everyone it comes out for the blondes
the latinos the japanese for everybody
the sun does not discriminate the rain
falls for every farmer
so i think it's a really beautiful image
of kind of hope in the midst
of a lot of destruction and um
challenges that our food system is
experiencing right now
um so of course i have my
acknowledgements my research assistants
and funding
and um and so forth but um
yeah i'll stop there and hopefully i
didn't go
too long i'm happy to answer
questions that people have
oh don i think you're muted now
sorry i think we've all been prayed to
that uh
fault in the zoom age so questions for
laura ann
and actually i'll lead with one uh which
is
did you find that generally these
latino latina farm families
wanted their kids to
uh perpetuate the farms
yeah it's a really good question and
it's one that i did always ask
um and i found a mix mix of responses um
they felt strongly that they wanted
their children to learn they wanted to
offer
this as an option and you know one
farmer
specifically said to me well this is
always a backup plan you can always fall
back
you know how to grow your own food and
that's a life skill that my kids should
know because i know it
um but a lot of them just like most
parents were like well i really want my
kids to go to college and i want my kids
to have
options and opportunities um so no one
was strictly saying
you know my children should take over
the farm i don't think there was any
pressure there i think they came to the
united states to give their children
other opportunities
that they didn't have and so i think a
lot of them felt hey if i can make a
successful business that my children
want to take over that's great and i did
actually see some of that
and in some of the most successful farms
they already had kind of college-age
children that have been through the
education system
you know in the u.s spoke perfect
english and decided to help with the
farm and they were the ones that managed
all the marketing and the markets and
that was really helpful for those
families um but then i had
talked to a lot of farmers that were
like oh i have a daughter she's learning
to be a dental hygienist and i'm so
proud of that
and yeah she wants to be part of the
farm great but it's not required so i
think there was a real mix
like any parent you know you want your
kids options
other questions
yeah i was kind of pursuing that one in
a little bit different direction too
that
it seems like really for cultural values
they're getting into a part of the
market that's almost impossible to make
a living at
and so that seems like it it's even more
challenging to get the farm kids to stay
on the farm that way
but so looking at the sort of our
end in the agricultural education
business as it were
um did you see any cases where
people did like the farming aspects of
its children
and had the potential to go to college
but they were interested in going to
agriculture rather
than into dental hygiene or something
that's sort of more
obvious ways to find a job
if you saw that what was driving that
i did see that a little bit um i can't
say there were a lot of cases
i can think of one in virginia
um you know and i think a lot of
i think i could speak to more to why i
think i didn't see it is i'm not sure
that they know that that exists as an
option um because again again i think
they're
they're really socially isolated um and
so in in terms of kind of like what your
options might be after high school i'm
not sure a lot of them were
hearing and i could be wrong because i
didn't ask that question specifically
um but i didn't hear a lot of people
talking about you know if i'm going to
stay
if i'm going to go to school i'm going
to really study agriculture
because i because their parents are not
networked in um with the same types of
resources that our farmers are they're
not you know when i would ask in the
usda office
um you know how do you reach out they'd
be like oh well we have our lists
and if someone comes to our office they
get on our list and it's like well if
people never come to your office they're
never going to get on your list
so i don't think their kids at the same
time were kind of in the know
of what ag schools have to offer
you know i'd say that's that's my
assumption because i really didn't hear
about it if they were going to go to
college they were getting away from the
farm
and if they were going to stay on the
farm they were just excited to stay on
the farm and help their parents with
so many needs you know it could be
english they could do so much to help
their family just by staying
no thanks for that laura ann if you look
in chat you'll see that there are a
couple of questions
there yeah so i see the one about
um the hmong community so do you think
the attitudes might exist
among other communities traditionally
farming such as the hmong
so interestingly i actually started my
dissertation work thinking i was going
to work with the hmong in california
specifically because i had some
connections with extension in stockton
and i think there are so many
similarities with these stories um
i realized quickly that i didn't learn i
didn't speak long and i spoke spanish
and i really needed to
not spend three years learning a new
language
um but i did do some interviews in
stockton
just in the start of this work and i
think um
there are a lot of overlaps the biggest
difference is that the hmong community
comes
in as refugees um and the
farmworker communities are coming in as
undocumented or
maybe documented immigrants so the
refugee communities
and i'm doing some work actually with
refugees in syracuse right now
refugee communities by no means do they
have lots of resources but they have a
different set of resources than other
immigrants and because there are so many
um the the rap program the
office of refugee resettlement has an
agricultural
funding stream for refugee farmers and
the hmong farmers have been really
successful
um in in taking advantage of those
resources which is great
um so i think a lot of their their
narratives and their histories are the
same in terms of why they're farming why
they want to teach their kids to farm
and in minnesota i actually saw latino
farmers and hmong farmers using the same
food hub and there was a relationship
there
but i think there's something really
different in the refugee groups that
come in and they don't work in
agriculture in the us
but then they get back into farming
because similar to other immigrants
that's what they know
so then it's really different for the
latino groups that are coming in
working in industrial agriculture as
their jobs and then getting into it
without any of the networks that the
refugees have so not to say like
one group is better off than the other
because it's not easy to be in either
group
obviously to start a farm but i think
they have somewhat different paths to
agriculture
and different sets of resources and
networks so the hmong are just more
networked in
um than farmworkers are
um but yeah it's a really good question
there's a lot of commonalities there
did that answer i don't know i can't see
um what options
on how digital agriculture what are your
oh
opinions sorry on how digital
agriculture would influence immigrant
farmers
and what could we do from technology
aspect to help them
um so in terms of digital agriculture
i might just ask what with digital
agriculture do you mean
um like the ways people are using cell
phones to track the markets
or other
maybe help me with the question
yeah laura this is you uh so in terms of
the digital agriculture is just
a new revolution of technology
dedicated for agriculture applications
so you know for example instead of using
uh heavy-duty agriculture machinery we
probably will use robots
and you know just such different you
know technologies
that can reduce you know the pesticide
applications stuff like that so i'm just
wondering overall how those technologies
would influence
immigrant farmers and how we could do
from the technology aspect to help them
if possible
yeah it's a good question um i hadn't so
one thing i saw
was well obviously everyone has cell
phones um and so
but they don't have a lot of access so
they have cell phones they don't have
access to capital
um to invest in technology right so
anything that increases the investment
the the edge in terms of investment
usually they would
it would they would fall behind unless
someone is like gifting them lots of
money and technology um you know i did
see that there were really simple
technologies that could be helpful
um in terms of um
you know apps to help them with
marketing you know i actually heard some
creative ideas from them
um you know not necessarily specific
agricultural technologies but the ways
that they could be using their phones
um for things like really simple
marketing translation
um you know the more that that they
could
be kind of getting a leg up because for
them they're really trying to catch up
with the technology that already exists
because they don't have the money to
invest um and in terms of like robotics
versus labor
again i think it largely puts them at a
disadvantage because what they have
is labor right i mean that's what they
have to offer they have their family
they have themselves
they are the workers um and that's what
they have that other farmers don't have
is that they don't have to hire the
labor
so i think in a lot of ways technology
you know unless they have the money to
invest in the technology themselves
which they don't
it's hard to imagine how technology can
help them
unless it's specifically technology that
helps them with these barriers that
they're already
struggling with you know so
um let's see so as far as other
questions
i can just go back to the chat um
speak to let's see if i can see if who's
still here it looks like okay so
elizabeth is still here
can you speak to some of the differences
you noticed among your respondents do
you notice that region gender years in
the us
shape experiences of becoming farm
operators um
yeah definitely um you know the longer
that
they had been in the u.s and they'd say
the longer that their
community had been established in the us
um
you know the the more established that
they were as farmers right the easier
time that they had
um and so i think that was really
different regionally um
so at the community that i worked with
in the northern neck of virginia
um it was a group of farmers that had
come in in the 1980s many of them had
been through
the legislation where they got um
you know legal status in the 80s they
just had
these really established small-scale
farms they'd come in with the
berry migrants and and they had already
kind of multiple generations they really
um they had more a sense of the market
and what they were doing
um and they also owned land because it's
just inexpensive to own land in certain
parts of virginia
that varied a lot with what i was seeing
in california so in california even
though there are many generations
of you know mexican and latino
immigrants
um i saw that there were
the the immigrant farmers there were
largely um
indigenous um from mexico they were
newer immigrants they were younger
um in california it's just so hard to
own land even
really established farmers don't own
land they rent land you have the whole
issue of water access
um so they were just in a very different
situation regionally in terms of
saturation of markets and access to
markets and access to resources
and they were a newer set of farmers um
so it really and that's just kind of
two examples that really contrasted um
but you know it really did depend
and then at the same time i saw a lot of
commonalities a lot of them
they were still had the same goals for
their farms in terms of keeping it small
and diverse and direct markets um
so i don't know if that answers i mean
there's a lot of other kind of factors
there
but it's a region definitely did matter
um see
i think the next question oh um from
richard uh
how many there are many examples latino
farmers
working their way into partnerships or
transitions with ongoing or retiring
american farmers the same
who are their current or former
employers did you see this as a
potentially large scale pathway to farm
ownership
or immigrant farmers within ambition
yeah i mean actually thanks for asking
because i didn't really discuss that but
i do think that
is the ideal situation is
it didn't see it happening very much
although there are some organizations
working on that obviously
um like farmland um and some of the
incubator farms are trying to
um be that middle path
um you know what i saw was more that
farmers were retiring and
and selling to developers or selling to
larger farmers simply because the farm
workers couldn't afford to purchase the
farm
um so it had to be a really in the few
place
situations where i saw it happening it
had to be a real mission
of the current operator you know i
really want to pass this on to my
employees
i really see that i'll take a hit here
economically but it's worth it for me
um so i guess i i think that that would
be ideal to see that happening
um but it's unfortunately i think the
farmers
in a lot of cases have to be willing to
make less money on the property and of
course it's not like farmers
have a ton of money that they're making
at this point so it's a i think it's a
hard one unless there was some kind of
subsidy for that transaction
which you know that could happen and
that would be great
i'm sorry did that answer
yes thank you yeah um yeah i know we're
going to meet
later today right more um
i think that was all the questions i see
on here hi laura
and i have a question thank you so much
for this talk uh
i actually got the opportunity to
interview
a local organic farmer in pennsylvania
because i'm working on this podcast
project and she had brought up
this article by chris newman
who writes about indigenous food ways
in north america and talked a little bit
about how the industrial farm complex
uh the way that we have thousands of
acres that are in production for
commodity crops
which is very different from what these
small diversified farms are
is a way of almost holding the land
uh that has been stolen from the
indigenous
uh farmers that had
farmed it for generations so i was
wondering if in your research you would
come across
anything like that and any ways that our
farm system could become more
sustainable
uh with these smaller diversified farms
or if really
uh because in the middle of the country
the land is a lot cheaper
but the fear is that as these older
farmers age out
the larger corporations are going to end
up just buying it and
consolidating even more land right i
mean and that is what we've seen
happening is this consolidation
of the land especially in the midwest um
so
i mean i guess is the question then do
we see anything
other than that happening like is there
a pattern
that's going against that yeah i would i
want to see some kind of positivity
i mean i i'd say yes i think in pockets
and i think what i
what is hopeful to me about my study
is that i do not think that these
farmers have been
captured in terms of studies
before so something i didn't talk about
is the ways that the usda doesn't
capture these farmers and so i think the
numbers are actually much higher
so most the farmers that i spoke with
are really off the grid in terms of you
know they
usually rent from someone else and the
person they're renting from is the one
that fills out the census
um and they may or may not be reporting
that this farmer is just renting
a few acres here and there because it's
so informal for many of them not
everyone but a lot of it was very
informal
and you know i'm hopeful all right i
definitely believe it's happening all
over the country um
you know i think as far as the kind of
resistance
to our current um
you know food system on a large scale i
do think we're going to have to create
more structural support for farmers like
this because they're struggling
um you know and and it's happening but
it's
it's happening against these odds and so
i think for us to have large-scale
transfer of land um there has to be some
kind of structural solution too it can't
just be
ad hoc how it's happening now and i
think the social movements that we see
in you know agricultural social
movements and
um you know immigration movements like
support that i think there's a large
social movement among beginning and new
farmers that wants to see
these you know um long-term inequalities
addressed
um you know from colonization to slavery
to
you know immigrants today um but i think
it's going to take a lot of political
will to make a really big structural
difference right it doesn't mean we
shouldn't continue to support the
movements doing the work but it's
you know i mean there's a push right now
i i just saw an article this morning
to get the biden administration you know
to actually support
african-american farmers right and so i
think there's a lot more talk about
these things right now and i think
political
there's a lot more talk and pressure and
that helps create the political will
so i'm hopeful today more so than i was
a few months ago about it
yeah thank you so much that was an
awesome answer thanks
any other anybody else
just wanted to say thank you i had a
chance to ask lori on a few questions
this morning
so i didn't want to steal any more air
time but i really appreciate your time
thank you so much
thanks thank you for coming twice
yeah and you and i have some time later
so okay great
oh my god i'm looking forward to it hi
i have uh i have one more question yeah
well this was an awesome talk this is
like the first uh
seminar i actually attended the semester
um
and uh i was just wondering like what
made you want to do your research on
um you know new immigrant farmers like
like what was
uh i guess the reason behind that i
don't know the drive
um yeah the so it
it started actually when i was an
undergraduate at cornell
i went and did some work in guatemala
i was looking at permaculture and
indigenous farming systems there
um and then when i i was really
interested in kind of traditional
farming
and sustainable food systems and then
when i came back to the us
i thought okay i really want to go work
on a farm and try farming
and i moved out to california to work on
farms
oh and i did some in new york and then i
was california
and what i really found is rather than
wanting to be a farmer myself
because i recognized how hard it was um
is i was really fascinated in the
connection between the guatemalan
farmers the mayan farmers and all the
farm workers on the farm that i worked
with
in california and that they were really
like you know they were
all essentially indigenous to central
america
and mexico that they were all farmers
right but that this one group was
you know farming in guatemala this other
group had immigrated to the us to work
on like a big
and you know organic farm in california
but they really had the same background
they talked about agriculture in the
same ways so for me i was really
interested in that connection between
you know small scale in latin america
and then
um farm workers in the u.s and how do we
highlight all the knowledge that
farmworkers come to the us with so
rather than just seeing them as workers
how do we see them as people with
knowledge that contribute to the food
system
so that was kind of how i got started on
the the path
to this project cool thank you
i really enjoyed it um i just uh
yeah i don't know my um i'm like first
generation born here my family's from el
salvador
and uh my grandma was a farmer then but
you know the civil war started there and
we're in new york city and it's just
like now i'm i'm like a new transfer
student at cornell studying like plants
and agriculture and
because it's something i'm really
interested in and i don't know i think
it's really cool that there's like
like there's just so many different ways
things could have gone um
and i don't know i just i think
immigration is
in farming is really important they're
really like the population that's doing
most of the farming here in the u.s now
people don't really want to farm anymore
but
it's like this is the backbone of our
country like this is what we eat and
stuff and
i i don't know this talk was really
really cool so thank you so much
thank you i agree with everything you
said
thanks so much i should get that
bye bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu